we're told that point PU was rotated
about the origin zero comma zero by
sixty degrees which point is the image
of P pause this video and see if you can
figure that out
alright now let's think about it it's
being this is point P it's being rotated
around the origin zero comma zero by
sixty degrees so if originally point P
is right over here and we're rotating by
positive sixty degrees so that means we
go counterclockwise by sixty degrees so
this looks like about sixty degrees
right over here one way to think about
sixty degrees is that that's one-third
of 180 degrees so does this look like
one-third of 180 degrees remember 180
degrees would be almost a full line so
that indeed does look like one-third of
180 degrees 60 degrees it gets us to
Point C and it looks like it's the same
distance from the origin we have just
rotated by 60 degrees point D looks like
it's more than 60 degree rotation so I
won't go with that one all right let's
do one more of these
so we're told Point P was rotated by
negative 90 degrees the center of
rotation is indicated which point is the
image of P so once again pause this
video and try to think about it alright
so we have our center of rotation this
is our point P and we're rotating by
negative 90 degrees so this means we are
going clockwise so we're going in that
direction and 90 degrees is easy to spot
it's a right angle and so it would look
like that and it looks like it is
getting us right to right to point a so
this is a negative 90 degree rotation
right over here gets us to Point a